wird in hamburg bald den ganze physik
revolutioniert die dunkle materie ist
wohl das größte rätsel der modernen
physik manchem fachleute vermuten dass
sie aus den sogenannten wiki interacting
massive particles bestehen kurzfilms
dabei handelt es sich um extrem
massereiche teilchen anderer meinung ist
man aber am deutschen
elektronen-synchrotron dem die sie in
hamburg hier wird mit einem
spektakulären experiment bald nach
besonders leichten partikeln gesucht und
mit diesen teilchen kann nicht durch
wände scheinen wie witte klick zum
science fiction hier gibt's täglich
spannende science videos abonniert im
kanal und aktiviert die glocken nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen das ist wirklich ein super
spannendes und einzigartiges
forschungsprojekt am deutschen
elektronen-synchrotron dem die see in
hamburg das heißt 12 und das steht für
annie leitartikel search dir suchen
internationalen forschungsteams eine
antwort auf die vielleicht spannendste
frage der modernen physik welche
eigenschaften machen die geheimnisvolle
dunkle materie aus für das neue
experiment wurde jetzt am 28 oktober
2009 10 der erste von insgesamt 24
supraleitenden magneten installiert die
spannende suche nach denen besonders
leichten teilchen findet in einem
bestimmten abschnitt des beschleuniger
tunnels am forschungszentrum in hamburg
statt gesucht werden teilchen die
achtung nicht durch eine wand scheinen
lassen können moment wie bitte ja licht
das durch eine wand scheint ein
möglicher kandidat ist das so genannte
aktion an teilchen das bisher nur in den
köpfen der fachleute existiert diese
teilchen für nicht zum standardmodell
der teilchenphysik doch mittlerweile
werden sie von vielen forschungsteams
weltweit als die favorisierten
kandidaten gesehen wenn sie existieren
könnten sie milliarden mal leichter sein
als ein elektron dafür aber umso
zahlreicher wenn diese teilchen
tatsächlich existieren dann müssen sie
sich durch den einfluss eines starken
magnetfeldes ab und an in lichtteilchen
umwandeln und umgekehrt und diese so
genannten photonen könnten in dem
hamburger experiment nachgewiesen werden
so die hoffnung der desi fachleute dazu
heißt es auf der webseite des
forschungszentrums ein beispiel ist das
aktion
das ursprünglich zur erklärung von
aspekten der starken wechselwirkung
einer der fundamentalen naturkräfte
postuliert wurde
es gibt auch rätselhafte
astrophysikalische beobachtungen in der
evolution von sternensystemen die sehr
gut durch die existenz von aktionen oder
aktionen ähnlichen teilchen erklärt
werden können bereits in den jahren 2007
bis 2010 wurde am de sie nach diesen
extrem leichten teilchen gesucht doch
die experimente blieben ohne erfolg
mittlerweile aber ist die messtechnik
verbessert worden
nun soll sie tausendmal empfindlicher
sein als damals ermöglicht wird das
durch die größere längen der magnet
strecke und durch die optimierung der
optischen technologien konkret sollen
die aktionen durch den einsatz von 24
magneten aufgespürt werden jeweils neun
meter lang sind zwölf von ihnen sind auf
der einen seite einer dicken stahl wand
aufgestellt und die anderen zwölf auf
der anderen seite hinzu kommt ein laser
system das einen strahl aussende der
zudem durch zwei sogenannte resonatoren
im inneren des magnetfeldes verstärkt
wird das so erzeugte licht wird nach
hoffnung der fachleute somit zumindest
zu einem kleinen teil in teilchen der
dunklen materie umgewandelt diese
aktionen sollten dann auch kein problem
mit der wand haben die vor der anderen
hälfte von 12 steht es handelt sich um
eine im licht blockierende barriere die
aber von aktionen oder ähnlichen
teilchen passiert werden kann
im gegensatz zu den photonen also den
lichtteilchen allerdings so die annahme
des des forschungsteams der zweite
resonators sorgt dafür dass die teilchen
der dunklen materie wieder in licht
umgewandelt werden spezielle
detektionssysteme könnten dieses winzige
signal dann erfassen wenn das
tatsächlich so passiert wäre dass
endlich der beweis für die dunkle
materie und das würde die gesamte physik
revolutionieren das projekt als zwei
findet übrigens in einem tunnel
abschnitt statt in dem in der
vergangenheit der teilchenbeschleuniger
von d sie stand auch die genutzten
magneten werden zweitverwertet
ursprünglich sorgten sie dafür dass
protonen durch den ring getrieben wurden
durch einen umbau und die entfernung
ihrer leichten biegung wird jetzt
gewährleistet dass sich das licht
ungehindert durch sie ausbreiten kann
ein gutes beispiel also für recycling in
der forschung und was das projekt auch
vergleichsweise günstig macht zum
fortschritt des projekts sagt axel
lindner vom dws
wirklich aufregend zu sehen wie das
projekt an dem viele von uns seit so
vielen jahren arbeiten endlich im tunnel
gestalt annimmt wenn die installation
und die inbetriebnahme wie geplant
verläuft können wir die messung in der
ersten hälfte des jahres 2021 staaten
der zufall das universum und du schaut
mal bei dem extrem spannenden kanals
capix in dem pub vorbei also anklicken
anschauen und wenn es euch gefallen hat
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran